what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have a lot of exciting MCU news
to talk about today we have some details
about Xiang Chi too we have some details
about the new Avengers team and some new
characters are joining the MCU which is
really exciting now first and foremost
some of you have been asking me in the
comments and on Twitter if Marvel
Studios is Phase 5 and phase six as
slates are going to be getting delayed
and sadly it does sound like that is
going to be the case as most people I'm
sure have heard there has been a lot of
different changes going on at Disney
right now there have been some changes
going on at Marvel Studios as well and
Kevin feige has recently came out and
said that they are now going to be
focusing over quality over quantity and
he specifically said in a recent
interview we are probably going to be
seeing less Disney Plus shows come out
per year and they are going to be more
spaced out which of course would simply
come with what's being put out but with
Kevin feige announcing that less shows
are coming per year it does seem like we
are are going to get a little bit of a
delay in the entire release schedule
including Avengers King Dynasty and
Secret Wars now this hasn't been
confirmed yet although a few insiders
online have said this but based off of
the way everything has been going so far
it does seem like we should expect some
delays in fact this year we're only sure
of two Disney Plus shows that are going
to be releasing from Marvel Studios that
is and that is Loki season 2 and secret
Invasion the rest unfortunately we are
unsure about right now and this report
is coming from The Hollywood Reporter
however this isn't necessarily a bad
thing if it means that we are going to
be getting better quality projects from
Marvel Studios and speaking of better
quality one of the best projects to come
from Marvel's phase 4 was Xiang Chi and
the legend of the ten rings of course it
has been confirmed that we are getting a
Shang Chi too it's also been stated by
some insiders that shangshi 2 is going
to be an incredibly important film
leading into the King Dynasty and this
is widely believed to be because of the
tin Rings themselves they are believed
to be made by Kang but today we were
given some other really important
details about xiangchi II according to
The Insider account film Odyssey on
Twitter variants of Kang will appear in
shangchi 2. now this fact combined with
the ending of the first shangchi film
gives us a little bit of info about what
the plot is going to be for shangchi too
it seems very clear at this point in
time that Xiang Chi and Katie perhaps
with the help of Wong are going to be
trying to find out the origin of the 10
Rings shanxi's father when Wu is no
longer around so they can't exactly ask
him where he got the Rings from yes
there have been myths and stories about
where winwoo found the Rings however
none of those are confirmed to be true
so we don't know at this point in time
when Wu could have found the Rings and
they could have been a technology from
Kang or perhaps somehow Kang ran into
win-woo and gave him the Rings or
perhaps maybe Kang even gave win-woo the
Rings without even revealing himself
perhaps he just put them in some place
where win-woo could find them so he
could start his dynasty in a a world
where Kang could simply control
everything anything is possible but now
we know that variants of Kang are going
to be in shanxi too so Xiang Chi is
going to be dealing with Kang before the
Kang Dynasty now what's interesting is
that chongqi does have the ability to
kind of go to an outer realm outside of
Earth talo talo exists in an outer
dimension of Earth and they showed us in
Shang Chi that talo has a very very long
and Rich history but they have battled
in the past perhaps they could have ran
into Ken in the past and perhaps
xiangchi is going to have to go back to
talo and deal with a variant of King
bear while at the same time he might
have to deal with a variant of King in
the normal world no doubt the other
kangs are going to send a king to our
world after the events of quantumania
the Avengers are on the radar now they
are viewed as threats now and they
seemingly have a piece of Kang
technology the 10 rings so it would make
sense that they would go after Shang Chi
who is kind of an Avenger now who has
King Tech so Xiang Chi 2 is already
looking pretty cool and right away if
you have any thoughts or theories on
this go ahead and let us know about them
in the comments down below now speaking
of Avengers like I mentioned we have
some new Avengers details also coming
from the same Insider account film
Odyssey on Twitter somebody tweeted out
a picture of Brie Larson's Captain
Marvel and Anthony Mackey's new Captain
America stating if they're not the
leaders of the new Avengers team what's
even the point in film Odyssey replied
they will be now this is coming from
recent rumors that Tom Holland
Spider-Man is going to be a leader of
the new Avengers team as well so people
are wondering well how exactly is
Spider-Man going to jump in and be the
leader well keep in mind that the new
Avengers team is actually supposed to be
assembled in Captain America 4 New World
Order and this team could be different
than the actual New Avengers team that
we get in the King Dynasty film Captain
America New World Order is supposedly
going to be somewhat like Captain
America Civil War With It basically
being an actual Avengers film without
the title and obviously since the movie
is about Captain America he is clearly
going to be a leader and I'm assuming
that Brie Larson's Captain Marvel is
going to come back for King Dynasty of
course this is when a bunch of the
different heroes are going to come
together the new Avengers team that was
formed under Captain America Brie
Larson's Cosmic team with the Marvels
and Spider-Man's going to jump in there
as well it's not unheard of for The
Avengers team to have more than one
leader Captain America was the leader of
the Avengers team but Tony Stark kind of
was as well and recently Anthony Mackey
kind of stated in an interview that he
doesn't really have any powers compared
to these other people kind of casting
doubts that he would lead the new
Avengers however in his own film he is
definitely going to be a leader but
going into the Kang Dynasty that could
be very very different and then of
course going into Secret Wars there's
definitely going to be many different
leaders because there are probably going
to be many different teams not only in
our universe but in others so as far as
the leaders of the new Avengers go it
does make sense to have Captain Marvel
Spider-Man and the Falcon but it looks
like some other awesome characters are
going to be joining the MCU rather soon
as we have gotten a report today that
Stephen young is joining the MCU now
most people know Steven Young from The
Walking Dead and most people know of his
famous death in that series but this is
great news because he is an incredible
actor and he will definitely do a great
job in the MCU now this is coming from a
report from deadline.com and they state
that he is joining however they do not
know which character he is going to play
but he is joining the Thunderbolts movie
at this point in time it's unclear on
whether or not he's going to be a hero
or a villain whether he's going to have
powers or not but the biggest
speculation right now is that he is
going to play Amadeus Cho a version of
the Hulk Amadeus Cho in the comics is a
Korean American and Steven young is a
Korean American as well and we do know
that the Thunderbolts is kind of going
to be about the Hulk and we know that
the Hulk and red Hulk are also going to
have a presence in Captain America 4
which the Thunderbolts leads up to so we
could have yet another version of the
Hulk Amadeus chose version of the whole
appearing in the Thunderbolts giving us
multiple versions of the Hulk and the
MCU we have the regular Hulk who is
Professor Hulk right now his cousin
She-Hulk we are expecting Red Hulk of
course to be coming in the Thunderbolts
and Captain America 4 and then we could
have Amadeus Cho so having all of these
hulks in the MCU and having the reports
about a World War Hulk movie being
developed at Marvel Studios right now is
a great sign that we are indeed going to
be getting that movie now obviously the
world war Hulk movie could differ from
the comics having all of these different
versions of the Hulk in one movie but
the movie does seem to be happening
especially if you consider that film
Odyssey has tweeted about this recently
stating yes they still plan on making
World War Hulk I've heard the
possibility of maestro Hulk being
included so they could have even more if
that is the case this movie sounds like
it's going to be absolutely phenomenal
and Captain America 4 and the
Thunderbolt seems like they're going to
be pretty great as well so Steven young
could be a new Hulk in the MCU this is
not confirmed this is just speculation
of course at the time although it does
kind of make sense logically but go
ahead and let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest MCU news for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf